I know enter welcome to this video why
is bride Paul playing 183 and nh3 that's
kind of weird when I know him a little
bit he's saying it was some starting a
book for everyman chess on on them on
what was that one night f3 and we
discussed something so but a little bit
surprised that he goes for such a lucky
opening system but what position is not
not terrible so what to do here before
it's probably not bad you can also take
antiquing is also making some sense I'm
in my position here I've got good pieces
it's not quite clear what he what is
going to do there long yeah okay I need
to open an open knob on the queenside
let's start yeah that is a kind of very
straightforward um yeah okay okay if I
go back then h4 h5 is probably going to
annihilate me some
let's go for the funky edge for it stops
the h-bond okay what is going on here
Knight f3 is the point okay I can't I
can do this first and then see about
details what is his plan 9 f3 I take the
before pawn so it cannot be the thing
okay I'm just opening this up he might
be able to win ce6 but well that's just
it happens yeah I can take before I mean
okay g7 hangs huh
I can't play Knights and sorry I can do
this it wasn't a Danny Katie takes it
with the Queen can take it with the
Queen
okay look before is also Quincy three
okay
taking a long time here to figure some
basic things out you know what i given
the exchange ha right that i can take
what are you doing here play reason with
a Reiki game what a wiki game yeah I
mean he can really take it and where I
thought that could be interesting maybe
not him I thought I get this meme which
is God can take take since exam it
really doesn't work I was a really wacky
game what was he doing there with a 3
and a 3 I don't know I didn't didn't
quite review it first for certain yeah I
should probably play for him and gain
more space there maybe a force stronger
and I know he s not cancelled let's look
at this critical these critical
situations here f4 hmm f4 out that makes
sense
but I would like to know what's going on
here I mean I am so jinx yeah I was
actually thinking this would work but I
have this now ok and it makes an awful
lot of sense like this and then take
this ok
so before is correct here look a3 is
even stronger it with the dead wings of
course and then is ksy the open is not
just the materials also the king
extremely strange game okay thanks for
watching